politics are getting personal for more
Americans on both sides of the political
aisle of recent CBS News poll found the
number of Democrats and Republicans with
negative views of the other party is
growing unfavorable ratings hit almost
90 percent on each side in recent years
but a group that calls itself better
angels is now trying to bridge the gap
people with differing opinions from the
same community talk face-to-face to ease
tensions Don Dahler visited one meeting
in Lebanon Ohio where 14 people on both
sides of the debate over gun control and
the Second Amendment come together Don
good morning so it is possible to have
it good morning it's a conversation you
know honestly this will give you some
hope yeah it was a great experience in
this climate there doesn't seem to be a
more divisive topic than gun control and
folks in our meeting in Ohio were
prepared to battle it out one man told
us he was expecting a firestorm but
these men and women did take on their
better angels and well a very
constructive conversation ensued I am
red voted for Trump I would describe
myself as a fierce partisan for blue at
bitter ranges meetings I'm a red I'm a
blue the colors are drawn and the
conversation is equally split the idea
is to stick to our own views and let
others describe there's David lap leads
the discussion and enforces the rules
this one is in what's called a fishbowl
the Reds on the inside and the blues
listening on the outside where do you
stand on the gun rights gun control
issue I'm adamantly seriously upset when
people start to try to infringe on that
Second Amendment
it really does disturb me we're in a
spiritual battle this is not a battle of
anything else it is a battle of good and
evil a training training training I know
with my grandchildren when I travel in
some areas first thing I say do we have
our guns because I'm poor I want to be
able to protect them
the Reds then have to confront downsides
to their ideas are we willing to pay
more taxes to put more security cameras
in our schools
next comes the blue team I don't see
myself in the second amendment although
I recognize it's there it should be like
every other
in the bill of rights that it's not
absolute why don't we have extreme
vetting for owning a gun but they also
had to face the downsides will there be
a black market sure there will be not
only is it gonna involve more funding
it's going to involve more bureaucracy
they too found that challenging I don't
see a downside this group in Lebanon has
been having these tough conversations
for over a year and a half and they
recognize it hasn't been easy
whether you're blue red doesn't matter
at the table you want to see something
happen and we all think realized that
doesn't come free before I came I was
just thinking about the other side
wouldn't it just be like very status quo
and and I think the openness to
understanding that there is an issue in
that proper training could could help
was a start so far over a thousand
people have taken part in the workshops
reaching thirty-one states almost 150
towns and cities will be launching
workshops this year is this more therapy
than debate it's not so much a debate as
it is to be enlightened because so we
have so many stereotype this gives us a
chance to see that it's not really the
way it is there were times when I saw
the listening group I saw clenched jaws
I saw how far is it not to say no wait a
minute that's not right you have to
listen it's extremely educational just
to hear what comes out of different
views including my own red friends is
there a part of you that you really want
to try to convince the other side and
you want to change some minds
I'd be chomping at the bit to go after
someone is broke that's not the
objective here the objective is to try
to see where we have common ground so
when you say therapy it is a kind of
therapy for us but my idea is to pass
this therapy on because this country
needs that kind of therapy that therapy
created a friendship between Greg Smith
a self-described Christian conservative
and Kuya our moose
an immigrant from Iran by confronting
stereotypes he said you go first I said
I have four initials for you four
letters is is I didn't have to say it qu
yaar said stop right there he said my
religion has been hijacked
I said you stop right there mine has two
and some from that point on we were able
to look for common ground now we travel
together we eat together we even pray
together despite what many people think
Americans are very United
we just need to demonstrate that to the
country and unfortunately only our
differences are being portrayed now by
the end of the evening the group found
the similarities were that they all
wanted to protect their children and
grandchildren and they all thought
training for gun owners was essential
they also told us unanimously that the
media were to blame for the hyper
partisanship in America why do they feel
that way done because they are in their
own echo chambers and these echo
chambers blame each other and what these
this group does is it helps people see
each other as human beings first we
might have political dissent but you're
human beings and the interesting thing
is some of them came into this with
stereotypes about each other they
thought all Republicans were racist they
thought all Democrats were just wanted
to tax me until I didn't have anything
left right and they found that those
stereotypes are not true right yeah
you've got to get out of your echo
chambers that's why it's so important to
do stories like this we could all use a
forum or a few more therapy sessions
done thank you